you get drafted and then you got like a
ton of stuff to do like as soon as you
get drafted then you go to summer league
like it was like a whirlwind summer for
you once you got back here to San
Antonio like what was kind of the focus
as far as like
what you wanted your development to be
you know I think you forgot something
actually even before I got drafted six
days before I think I was still playing
in the Championships yes I skipped that
part but yeah you're right like I don't
have to do that's right but uh ever
since I came back
it's the focus has really been on yeah
basketball
body
is we've been working harder and smaller
than ever
really it's I've discovered I mean I was
expecting the expertise and the all the
all the tests here to be more thorough
but I was still surprised by how how
Technical and serious it was you know
and it's
it's gonna make this off season that I
just spent is gonna make a huge
difference in my life I heard you
earlier to talk about how like you kind
of are like in way better shape already
then you then you've been in like how
long like the last two or three years I
mean I mean ever no ever because
actually I've never had a summer like
this that I could spend working on on
myself
because I always had the national team
or some some the youth national teams
you know uh keeping me busy so it's it
was really precious to me no one overall
Pig obviously there's going to be tons
of expectation from the outside world
but really what for you what's realistic
and attainable for you you know the the
only expectations that matter are my
teammates my coaches and and mines so
it's I don't care about the rest but um
you know it's what's realistic
and uh ambitious to me was would be
going to the playoffs
and uh but uh I'm just I
I'm just a rookie I don't know much
about the NBA everyone in here knows
more about it every player every coach
so I'm really willing to to to to to
work and to learn from Bemus as quick as
I can because I want to win you know I
was talking to pop earlier and he was
talking about how like one thing he he
finds really interesting about you is
just the level of maturity he was
talking about how like you know you're
going around town meeting the people
signing the murals and things like that
like where does that approach come from
and you look genuinely thankful for the
love you're getting out here me going
around town isn't related to maturity it
was just me having fun you know it's
uh because
I mean it's these people are showing me
love just like just just like I'm family
already and even though they never met
me they don't know me so it's I really
feel thankful for this